Sly always gives the best advice he
always said if you want to get someone's
attention and you don't know what to say
to them on text say nothing cuz nothing
translates to that person better than
any text that you could be Conjuring up
and try to get their attention try to be
a little bitter nothing reads so much
louder and so I've realized I'm like
hold on here's the secret and it sucks
and obviously you want to call it
playing games I call it playing smart
and protecting your heart how to get
someone to to chase you okay do nothing
if you want them to text you the more
you show disinterest and distance
yourself that is when you're going to
actually see how much they are
interested in you if he doesn't answer
if he doesn't notice if he doesn't care
he just showed you his cards he showed
you exactly how he feels about you